[Musique]
l'historique villa du département s'est
habillé pour les 70 ans de la sdr la
société immobilière du département de la
réunion
créée en 1949 a contribué à donner un
toit à de nombreuses familles au
lendemain de la départementalisation
je suis né là chaque année pour moi
parce que nous même les réunionnais
rorive est un des paillotes ennuis dans
des cages on n'avait pas les créanciers
n'avaient pas de l'eau tu fais que
passer des arts est arrivé c'était la
lumière aujourd'hui ces visages sont au
centre de la vie de ces logements
sociaux une nécessité pour se souvenir
on ne peut pas bâtir à l'avenir si
d'abord on n'arrive pas à loger une
famille parce que quand on loge une
famille on sait que les enfants autant
cadre qui leur permettent d'étudier à
l'école et ils représentent l'avenir de
là réunion le département travaille avec
les cd r et nous voulons plus de
logements des logements adaptés
notamment à nos gramounes et aux
personnes en situation de handicap qui
vivent dans les logements des sidéens
d'esope donc des adaptations pour que
ces familles se sentent bien chez elle
partout ces bailleurs sociaux ont changé
le territoire réunionnais un
investissement dans les entreprises
locales au bénéfice de la population
sous le contrôle de la collectivité un
équilibre idéal pour appréhender
l'avenir la construction d'une
l'entreprise de commenailles si dr
s'arrête jamais parce que la
construction de la réunion non plus ne
s'arrête jamais et en réalité le grand
enjeu maintenant pour les 70 ans qui
viennent c'est que dans 70 ans entre le
coleader a bien répondu aux besoins
réels des réunionnais c'est ce dans quoi
nous sommes engagés
avec des milliers de logements sociaux
en attente le contexte réunionnais donne
de nombreuses perspectives aux missions
confiées à la sdr par le conseil
départemental
[Musique]
hamon